alors il y a quelques sondages
qui montrent que le Président de la
République connaît un petit regain de
popularité ou au moins que son
impopularité cesse de se creuser
elle a été forte pendant la crise enfin
le débat sur les retraites il se trouve
que c'est de mémoire la troisième fois
je crois que Ben après une baisse quand
même assez assez forte après les gilets
jaunes il a
il a repris un peu les couleurs et après
la crise sanitaire il a repris des
couleurs et là on croyait définitivement
en cale minée il reprend des couleurs
aussi
est-ce que c'est c'est dû à quoi
d'ailleurs
martial martial Foucault il y a je vois
deux raisons la première c'est que au
fond alors il pouvait essayer de
rejoindre le club très fermé des
présidents un peu plus l'air et dont le
chef de fil François Hollande avait
atteint 13%
il était autour de 19 20% on donne des
chiffres parce que c'est important quand
on parle d'un popularité d'avoir quand
même ces références
[Musique]
cette dynamique à la baisse a été cassée
je crois tout simplement
par ces alors c'est pas seulement le
plan de 100 jours c'est que depuis
maintenant un mois Emmanuel Macron
occupe l'espace quotidien il est très
présent médiatique au gré d'intervention
et de déplacement en France de
déplacements à l'étranger se permettant
de commenter aussi l'actualité politique
française à l'étranger ce qui est quand
même une nouveauté et donc effectivement
il a cassé cette cette dynamique à la
baisse et ça les Français lui sont
reconnaissants au fond d'être sortis de
sa tour d'ivoire puisqu'on lui a fait le
reproche pendant tous les débats des
retraites de ne pas être intervenu il y
a une deuxième raison qui à mon avis ne
tient pas à l'action d'Emmanuel Macron
quand on regarde dans le détail cette
cette popularité
renaissante on observe que ce
essentiellement les électeurs qui
avaient voté pour Emmanuel Macron en
2022 et qui depuis le mois de octobre
novembre s'interroger sur son action qui
le rejoignent de nouveau donc en fait il
récupère ses électeurs qui étaient un
petit peu exaspéré par ce débat qui
n'était pas suffisamment
canassée le président qui faisait de
cette réforme de la retraite un peu
l'alpha et l'oméga de son début donc
c'est un électorat c'est dommage et
diplômé quoi diplômés les catégories
supérieures métropoles et c'est
important par rapport à ce que l'on
disait tout à l'heure qui n'ont pas fait
de la réforme de la retraite
l'essentiel du choix de vote pour
Emmanuel Macron donc c'est important de
voir que c'est un électorat qui se dit
finalement il n'y a peut-être pas
aujourd'hui
d'altern dans l'offre politique
française en fait c'est vrai que
Emmanuel Macron est tout seul sur la
scène politique non seulement il est
seul sur le centre droit
son espace mais en plus il est seul face
aux extrêmes face à la seule et il y a
deux autres figures qui émergent chez
Madame Le Pen et voilà Monsieur
en fait et donc il a une place une place
de choix moi je dirais deux autres
pardon j'avais deux autres purement
purement technique c'est qu'on arrive à
la fin d'une
séquence très pénible des retraites très
longues donc je pense qu'il y a dans
l'opinion des ras-le-bol en fait passer
à autre chose et puis aussi on arrive à
l'été c'est aussi un moment où ça
retombe la tension avec le printemps
je sais pas
[Rires]
moi je trouve que l'absence
d'alternative dans son espace politique
est un élément fondamental c'est pour ça
qu'il y a ces qu'on en est au troisième
rebond c'est qu'à chaque fois les gens
se retourne ils se demandent qui pour
faire mieux que lui et
les dans cet espace les gens répondent
personne donc par défaut Emmanuel Macron
remonte première chose deuxième chose
malgré le styleté
exprimé à la réforme des retraites dans
dans l'opinion qui d'après les sondages
et ultra majoritaires
si Emmanuel Macron reconstitue son socle
électoral c'est parce qu'il a tenu et on
peut même si ça paraît paradoxal être à
la fois opposé à la réforme des
retraites et reconnaissant au président
de la République de ne pas avoir cédé
devant la rue la prime alors il y a une
autre il y a peut-être deux autres a pas
de raison d'ailleurs qui sont parfois
évoquées par les commentateurs de
sondages alors je m'appuie pour ce thème
sur un sondage notamment c'est un
sondage BVA pour RTL qui lui donne 4
points de plus par rapport à
là où il était c'est-à-dire que je crois
qu'il était à 9 29 % dans de popularité
dans ce cet institut et qui monte
maintenant à 33 34% enfin c'est pas
tellement c'est faut relativiser tout ça
quand même mais alors il y a deux
explications il y en a qui disent il a
fait des sorties importantes sur le plan
thématique notamment sur l'industrie
il y a eu le sommet de choses France où
il a montré aussi que la France était
entrepreneuse et entreprenante plutôt et
que on pouvait investir dans notre pays
et puis aussi dit-on mais je sais pas si
c'est vrai que
toutes les séquences et on est en plein
dedans mémorielles entre Jean Moulin le
Conseil National de la Résistance
Mont-Saint-Michel aujourd'hui
il est
il est il célèbre le commando Kieffer
sur les plages du débarquement et
bientôt ça sera le 18 juin où il sera au
Mont Valérien avec Manoukian le réseau
Manoukian tout ça peut aussi avoir un
impact sur l'opinion publique oui on
sait que les présidents se sont toujours
référés à l'histoire quand leur code de
popularité était en berne donc
évidemment cela compte à mon avis mais
les Français ont aussi un réflexe
légitimiste et quand vous avez évoqué
les moments de crise et ensuite la cote
du popularité qui repart là nous avons
quand même vécu une crise politique et
évidemment en fait le simple le seul
réflexe qui peut y avoir derrière c'est
de trouver un espoir dans la personne
qui gouverne quand même quand surtout
quand Emmanuel Macron
il aurait aimé avoir ça il l'a jamais eu
oui mais c'est vrai qu'il ouvre aussi
comme vous l'avez noté plusieurs grands
chantiers et donc on peut se dire et
finalement il baisse pas les bras alors
même qu'il était contestés et c'est
peut-être parce qu'avait fait le sel de
sa réussite au départ Emmanuel Macron
c'était de dire
je fais fille des oppositions et je
garde un cap parce que je veux réformer
la France et c'est peut-être au moins ce
qu'on peut lui reconnaître aujourd'hui
il faut rajouter un point parce que
c'est parfois on est un peu perturbé par
cette cette mesure de la popularité
c'est pourquoi qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'on cherche à obtenir de la part du
français interrogé la popularité bon
c'est une mesure qui a bientôt 50 ans
l'Ifop a créé dans les années 60 l'outil
que je peux suivre et c'est vrai que
avant c'était une fois par semaine on
avait une mesure donc quand on répondait
c'était le thermomètre pour 6 mois bon
aujourd'hui c'est presque une mesure par
semaine et quand on prend vous parliez
du sondage BVA je regardais le sondage
yugov alors là c'est plus huit points
pour Macron en deux mois bon ça veut
dire qu'il y a quand même une tendance à
l'os et moi je pose toujours la question
qu'est-ce qu'on mesure on mesure un
amour pour l'action d'un président
une satisfaction ou bien le contraire
c'est à dire quand vous avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est moins pire je pense que
c'est exactement l'expression ça vous
voyez ça en fait c'est à dire que
pourquoi François Hollande pourquoi
Nicolas Sarkozy n'ont pas bénéficié de
tels rebonds il faut bien voir que ils
avaient pour ces deux présidents un seul
opposant
opposant de gauche ou opposant de droite
il y avait une figure j'allais dire qui
qui s'opposait pour Emmanuel Macron il
bénéficie tout à fait d'oppositions
morcelées ou atomisées et donc on n'a
pas un jeu complémentaire c'est-à-dire
j'aime ce président et donc je n'aime
pas son opposant ou je déteste ce
président et j'aime son opposant pour
Emmanuel Macron et plutôt apprécié des
français et l'opposant à Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui Marine Le Pen c'est
justement ça qui crée aussi
de cette situation c'est c'est que cela
crée en même temps une crise politique
parce qu'on a on n'a pas tendance comme
un président droit de gauche à assumer
par exemple d'aller directement vers un
extrait qui serait donc ici représenté
par Marine Le Pen mais forcément que
c'est quand même aujourd'hui la seule
force de position qui existe avec une
singularité c'est que effectivement
Marine Le Pen je suis d'accord avec vous
un des niveaux de d'adhésion très élevé
on est autour de 30-35%
mais ça veut dire que tous les opposants
Emmanuel Macron ne parviennent pas à
avoir 50%. ce qui n'était pas le cas
des opposants à Nicolas Sarkozy ou à
François Hollande c'est on voit bien que
là c'est le morcellement de cette
opposition qui ne permet pas à quelqu'un
de s'imposer donc Emmanuel Macron est
presque protégé par ses opposants le
fait qu'il n'arrive pas à dominer dans
l'opinion publique comme un un acteur
politique aimé des Français et bien le
protège et donc au gré des événements il
faut peu de choses une actualité et là
on peut je pense reconnaître Emmanuel
Macron qui s'en sort plutôt bien sur ces
opérations de communication politique
alors en même temps il y a elles avaient
de bornes qui suit un peu la même
tendance et ce qu'il a intérêt et ce
qu'il va changer de Premier ministre ou
de Première ministre d'ici au 14 juillet
alors ou après le 14 juillet alors
pour raisonner sur le fond
je trouve que le changement de Premier
ministre doit procéder du projet
politique la question que je me pose
c'est est-ce que le sursis d'Elizabeth
borde je parle de sursis parce qu'on
sait que l'agace terriblement d'ailleurs
il se prive pas de la sermonnée quand
elle tient des propos par exemple sur
Pétain sur le pétard et le rassemblement
national donc on sent que c'est pas
vraiment
la tension de mésentente entre eux et
pourquoi est-elle en sursis hypothèse
optimiste parce que Emmanuel Macron se
demande d'abord quoi faire
avant de se poser la question du avec
qui mais peut-être c'est trop optimiste
peut-être qu'il a juste pas
de nom qui lui conviennent dans la tête
peut-être qu'après tout elle ne lui fera
pas d'ombre
et leur représentera jamais de menace
s'il n'est pas évidemment il sera pas
candidat mais en tout cas il y aura des
choix à faire pour pour la suite le
prochain le prochain quinquennat il aura
des choix politiques à faire donc elle
est relativement confortable en plus
elle est elle est solide elle se laisse
pas abattre elle présente quand même des
qualités de confort pour un président de
la République qui n'a pas l'air d'avoir
un projet extrêmement clair dans la tête
d'accord Emmanuel est-ce que chez les
républicains partie que vous fréquentez
de temps en temps plutôt plus que moi on
nourrit ici et là c'est certain le
l'ambition de devenir peut-être le
premier ministre Macron ça a été
évidemment que une offre de Premier
ministre ça peut faire changer les idées
très vite
mais aujourd'hui là c'est pas vraiment
dans les tuyaux
on a parlé on a fait circuler des noms
notamment même celui de Gérard Larcher
publiquement
et donc ça vous fait sourire
on l'entendait nous-met lui il avait
pensé que c'était pas utile de le dire
aussi clairement qu'il l'a dit il a
quand même été obligé de faire une télé
pour ça mais non je pense que les
républicains ils sont dans une phase là
où très affaiblie énormément souffert
ils ont failli disparaître
cette séquence immigration c'est la
première lueur qui apparaît dans le ciel
de la droite depuis la présidentielle
d'accord ils avaient commencé cette
reconstruction avec un espoir sur les
retraites en disant en allant sans
partout en claironnant nous allons être
la force d'appoint de l'assemblée et
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
bon ce sont des visés patatras ça a
explosé
ils ont pas pu d'ailleurs ça ça leur a
posé de gros problèmes ils n'ont pas pu
être audible donc ça ça complètement
massacré leur stratégie de
reconstruction et là avec cette séquence
immigration parallèlement il y a
énormément de chantiers qui sont lancés
il y a une bon c'est toujours les mêmes
chantiers c'est on construit avec un
projet de reconstruction des ateliers il
va y avoir le 17 juin une grand-messe
des pour la refondation du parti au
Cirque d'Hiver ils ont lancé une école
des cadres ils ont lancé un média il ils
ont un signe tank aussi externe aux
parties qui va s'animer enfin s'appelle
c'est pas encore le nom mais c'est Jean
Leonetti le maire d'Antibes il va qui va
qui va s'en charger donc l'idée c'est de
créer une force extérieure pour pouvoir
nourrir le parti bon c'est toujours des
chantiers classiques ça quand il y a un
parti qui a beaucoup souffert mais
aujourd'hui la vérité c'est que Éric
Ciotti qui
est arriver dans le jeu sans imaginer
les problèmes qu'il allait avoir à
résoudre et erikiotti est en train de
construire quelque chose une offre et
bon c'est un peu difficile de savoir ce
qui va se passer mais
en tout cas il est en train d'organiser
les choses pour que si un rebond est
possible ce serait possible et
l'immigration le projet migration c'est
c'est vraiment le symbole de cette
stratégie il y en aura d'autres
il y a aussi
le fait que le Président de la
République on l'a évoqué ne peut pas se
présenter
en 2027 donc pour lui le temps va
commencer à être long dans très peu de
moi
son autorité même risque d'être un peu
contesté et contestable
l'action qui se posait Emmanuel Macron
c'est qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire est-ce
qu'il veut un héritier ou est-ce qu'il
en veut pas moi j'ai pas du tout la
réponse aujourd'hui je sais pas si
lui-même là finalement mais c'est ça qui
va se jouer aussi et est-ce que il va
vouloir aller au bout des chantiers qui
va lancer pour marquer l'histoire en
tout cas pour marquer au moins ce
deuxième quinquennat et est-ce qu'il va
vouloir ensuite lancer quelqu'un à sa
suite ou bien est-ce qu'il va tous les
laisser
voilà se disputer c'est terrible votre
pronostic Judith c'est très difficile de
savoir parce que
ce qui me frappe le début depuis son
élections 2017 chez Emmanuel Macron
c'est son côté frigoli les frigolis ce
personnage transformiste qui change
complètement au gré des situations on ne
sait jamais devant quelle Macron on se
trouve il est profondément
contradictoire donc à mon avis
profondément non structuré parce que
quand on est solidement structuré on
peut pas se livrer à ses volts auxquels
il nous a habitués
donc quoi à transmettre quel côté quel
Macron un
héritage à transmettre première chose
deuxième chose
une relation politique personnelle font
qu'on son âge aussi s'ajout mine de rien
même si les présidents de la République
sur son ascendant
un plus jeune que lui encore plus jeune
on voit pas très bien comment ça
pourrait avoir lieu martial je
rajouterais deux points la question de
l'héritage elle me semble très très
importante je continue à penser que
Emmanuel Macron contrairement aux autres
présidents passés n'a pas cette cette
longue histoire politique et qui ne l'a
pas amené à vivre dans la vie de partis
politiques à être candidats d'autres
élections notamment locales alors ça
amène me semble-t-il Emmanuel Macron a
essayez d'être un président qui dans
l'histoire aura marqué la vie des
Français bon il lui reste quatre ans
parce que aujourd'hui le bilan est quand
même assez mitigé après six ans donc il
a cette volonté d'être un président qui
est marqué mais il y a une deuxième
contrainte je crois que ça devient une
contradiction à vrai dire c'est que à ne
pas vouloir désigner d'héritiers je
pense qu'il ne le fera pas
il a une peur
sans mauvais jeu de mots mais il a une
peur bleue c'est qu'il soit le président
qui a installé Marine Le Pen
à l'Elysée et donc il n'a pas envie de
lui serrer la main après l'élection
présidentielle de 2027 donc est-ce que
cette hantise va l'amener à modifier
ça j'allais dire son rôle en vue
l'élection présidentielle de 2027 si
véritablement il a cette cette anxiété
interne alors il va être obligé de
sortir en quelque sorte du bois et
dédouber soit un membre de la macronie
historique ou bien il devra prendre une
position vis-à-vis de son ancien Premier
ministre Edouard Philippe s'il lui-même
et candidat ça fait pas d'autres pour
vous aujourd'hui il doit Philippe fait
tout pour essayer d'être candidat ou oui
il fait il pose des petits cailloux quoi
parce qu'il est fait tout pour être
candidat mais sans que personne ne s'en
rende compte il y a deux ans là où les
doit être à la fois présent mais discret
et puis
je pense qu'il y a un élément important
un moment très important mais peut-être
que d'ailleurs le calendrier n'aidera
pas
la macronie c'est les prochaines
élections importantes sont celles de
2026 élections locales régionales pour
Macron absolument et ça de ce côté là je
pense qu'Edouard Philippe a un avantage
par rapport à son réseau
qu'il est en train de de voilà d'établir
le maillage du territoire il est en
train d'essayer de faire vivre sa
formation avec des représentants alors
que du côté de redescence il y a une
grande difficulté quand on voit les
comités locaux ils sont plutôt désertés
et donc ça ça pose quand même problème
pour 20